when director Ryan coogler's black
panther hit the big screen in 2018 it
quickly proved itself as an absolute
Game Changer in the world of superhero
Cinema the film became a pop culture
phenomenon in short order with the
Ripple effects of its impact continuing
to reverberate throughout media today a
huge part of that is Thanks To The Man
Behind the titular hero Chadwick Bozeman
Bozeman much like King t'challa himself
was a fighter who inspired all who knew
him when he passed away on August 28
2020 due to colon cancer he left behind
a massive void in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and in the hearts of his
colleagues and bands across the globe
it's a void that will likely never be
filled when Bozeman died movement on a
black panther sequel was already
underway the loss of the legendary actor
was massive enough that director Ryan
coogler almost made a life-changing
decision to walk away from the
entertainment business however after
some time he instead decided to Pivot
his sequel to put the death of Bozeman
and the character he made famous fronted
center now to carry on this Legacy black
panther wakanda forever is on its way to
theaters as the final theatrical
installment to phase four the story sees
wakanda more in the sudden loss of
t'challa though they don't have long to
dwell on his demise due to attackers
from an underwater Kingdom led by Namor
however t'challa's sister shuri his
former rival in Baku and more make it
clear that they won't give up their home
to these Invaders without a fight a
lucky few have gotten to check out black
panther wakanda forever early and
thankfully they appear thoroughly
impressed with all that it has to offer
early reactions to Black Panther wakanda
forever flooded social media on October
27th and it became abundantly clear that
Ryan coogler the entire cast and crew
and Marvel Studios have at large
produced yet another home run one tweet
put it well saying wakanda forever is
Blockbuster filmmaking on another level
it surpasses the incredible first film
with high stakes and thrilling World
building and made the Bold claim that it
could be the best MCU entry yet several
other Twitter users shared similar
feelings about the movie while praising
its score from composer Ludwig Goranson
another user offered up some high marks
for wakanda forever as well posting
there's never been a CBM like it really
strong performances all around too
although this particular fan does feel
Neymar's motives were a little
underdeveloped but not necessarily to
the story's detriment of course the big
question when it comes to wakanda
Forever is how does it feel tonally
appropriately it largely lacks at
jokiness we've all come to expect from
MCU Productions one user tweeted Ryan
coogler's black panther wakanda forever
above all else is cathartic an emotional
movie about loss Legacy and healing
while another noted that while it's a
serious feature it's not without its
uplifting moments the female cast gets
plenty of time to shine as they're
celebrated for carrying the Black
Panther franchise forward and amid all
the emotion there are still some fun
surprises to look forward to all in all
from the performances to the tone to the
soundtrack to the story black panther
wakanda forever seems like an absolute
Triumph for all involved sure it's not
perfect and many will have their
complaints when it arrives but based on
these early reactions and numerous
others those who dislike it will more
than likely fall into the minority
wakanda forever premieres in theaters on
November 11 2022
foreign